jamie lee curtis stopped by jimmy kimmel
live and talked all about her daughter
ruby's upcoming cosplay wedding as she
gears up to officiate the ceremony
full costume take a look
tomorrow i love you my youngest daughter
my elder daughter annie was married
three years ago in the backyard to her
lovely husband jason wolfe i see and now
you're young and now ruby and cynthia
are getting married in the backyard i am
officiating in may
um it is a cosplay
wedding
is it really it is a cost
play wedding tell me exactly what that
means that means you do you wear a
costume you dress up as something so
everybody at the wedding is going to be
in costume and i will be in a costume uh
to officiate the wedding so it's really
exciting we're going to have a beautiful
picnic in the backyard i'm really
excited both my children will have been
married in my backyard which brings me
to tears yeah and it's cheaper right
it's so much cheaper in the yard
i mean that's
so much more meaningful i can't even
begin just in just just
forgetting all of show off business
being a parent
yeah having both of your children
married in your backyard yeah
it's just in your home yeah and you're
dressed as a raccoon you know